this was never about money for for mr
depp
so this was about restoring his
reputation and he's done that did johnny
depp's lawyers just hint the actor may
not collect his 10.4 million dollar
payout from ex-wife amber heard here's
what we know benjamin chu and camille
vasquez dropped by good morning america
on wednesday they rep johnny in his
defamation suit against amber which he
won last week and save the actors more
than satisfied with the outcome george
we obviously can't disclose
attorney-client communications but as mr
depp testified and as we both made clear
in our respective closings this was
never about money for for mr deb
so this was about restoring his
reputation and he's done that so they
won't say for sure what will happen but
since it seems unlikely that amber can
afford the damages johnny might accept
little to no payout it sounds like
that's something that could be on the
table but it's up to ms heard again we
have to be careful what we say
but this was about mr depp's reputation
that was what it was about for him it
was a total win for johnny
[Music]
and he seems to be riding high on the
win in court and the court of public
opinion it was like
the weight of the world had been taken
off his shoulders and i feel that
finally after six years he's gotten his
life back the actor signed up for
tick-tock after the high-profile trial
ended clips from the case went viral on
the app over the course of the six-week
legal battle
there is no question pending and i would
appreciate it if you wouldn't be making
argument to the jury sorry i thought you
would ask me about it
no i didn't ask you about anything in
his first video johnny thanked his loyal
and unwavering supporters and promised
to move forward together which didn't
sit right with amber her spokesperson
told et quote as johnny depp says he's
moving forward women's rights are moving
backward and in a separate statement
amber's team slammed johnny's lawyers
for making the press rounds after the
trial quote it is as unseemly as it is
unprofessional that johnny depp's legal
team has chosen to do a victory lap for
setting back decades of how women can be
treated in the courtroom now for what
it's worth amber's lawyer also made the
tv rounds before johnny's well her next
move is appeal there was another
heartbroken she is heartbroken cut to
camille on wednesday she fired back at
amber's claims that talking about the
case is unprofessional i think it's
disappointing we're only
speaking about what happened in this
case right and the facts in this case
were overwhelmingly positive for johnny
and the verdict speaks for itself
camille who became a breakout star of
the trial also refutes claims that
johnny's win sets back the metoo
movement and might make victims of
domestic abuse afraid to speak out you
don't see this as a setback to the
movement in any way shape or form
we do not we believe that
the verdict speaks for itself the facts
are what they were
the jury made a unanimous decision based
on those facts camille even goes as far
as to point out that all evidence in the
case came from amber i think that her
impression on the jury was
what it was
i think something that i focused on and
we focused on in that cross-examination
was using her words against her and it
was very important for us to every
question that was asked was tied to
something she had said previously and
i think the jury got to see and the
world got to see and hear from miss
heard
in that relationship
on every single topic
you